any case uh welcome to uh
stanford's the ee 380 uh
the computer systems uh colloquium
uh for uh uh
2020 fall and um
our uh speaker today is going to talk
about purple
air now you may or may not remember but
california in particular has uh spent a
great
deal of time uh in a blanket of smoke uh
living here in northern california is a
little bit like
living in the middle of a fireplace uh
these days
and uh one of the ways in which uh
many of us tracked the uh the uh
problems of the conflagration uh
was to track the uh air quality
and purple air has come up with a
marvelous mechanism to essentially
crowd source the sensors and
uh today's speaker uh is going to tell
us a little bit about what they do and
how they've done it and what sort of
success they've seen
um it's a it's a great thing
um and i'm bought
into the into the whole thing i have
on order because things are back ordered
these days
a pair of sensors which
i'm looking forward to receiving and
then placing on the network along with
everyone else
um in any case adrian
our the ceo is uh going to uh tell us a
little bit about this
very small company out in the middle of
utah
which has done wonderful things adrian
the the screen is yours so to speak
thank you hello dennis and um thank you
for having me um
and for the interest in purple air um i
know we've seen a lot of
interest from california due to the
wildfires and um
so i'm here to tell you a little bit
about purple air how we started and and
what we do
um purple air is a an equality
monitoring network and it's built on a
new generation
of low-cost internet of things
sensors which really just means devices
that communicate to the internet
and upload data to the cloud
so um poplar started in about 2015
the end of 2015 i was curious about the
gravel pit that we that's behind our
house
and how much dust was coming out of it
because every day i would watch the dust
blow over bluffdale
and it seemed like a lot of dust and i
said to myself hey this is 2015.
there has to be a device that i can use
to measure the
air quality and being an
engineer with some hardware and surface
mounts and
programming background i decided to try
to make my own
and the picture on here in the top left
is is actually some of the early sensors
with the
control boards that we used and uh the
top right picture is the
bowl design that we used initially to
house the sensor and make it resilient
against the environment
and as you go around on that you see
some of the latest to the where you see
in the middle
what our sensor looks like nowadays
we had no local government sensors
apart from 20 miles away in the central
salt lake city
and our desire was to share data openly
make it easy to
view and to to look at on a map
and so in the beginning to um we didn't
know what the census did or what they
meant and so we gave away
about 80 senses to volunteers who joined
the network through
facebook and other um sort of channels
and we gave them those early ones away
the sensor was then we sent three of
them to be tested by the aq spec
program and also
other like the university of utah they
also
were testing our sensor very early on in
the beginning
and basically it says that testing that
really led to
the explosion that we see now because
the test came back
very positive so uh purple air
is and what we call an end-to-end
service what makes us different is that
we provide the way of storing the data
and the way of viewing the data
a lot of sensors that you might buy off
the shelf just have you just get the
sensor you don't have any way of sharing
that data or recording it over time
so we provide the iot connected sensors
the data storage
and api for people to access the data as
well
and a map for people to view it another
very
important part of what we do is our
partner application ecosystem
which is uh basically people that write
applications that let's say an ios
application
for iphone or an android application uh
that they will
put onto the the various um stores
and uh and then you know share share
their
thing with people so um
yeah it's it's very important the
all-around
end-to-end inside of it so proper
sensors
they measure and report pm1 pm 2.5 and
pm10 we use a laser counter
which uses
[Music]
a laser beam to count and estimate the
particles that they're seeing in the air
the size and the counter particles
in six different size bins as they call
it uh from 0.3 microns up to 10 microns
in size
now there was a potential question
around the influence of humidity on on
the readings
and so we included a temperature
humidity and pressure sensor in case
there was
this influence that we could then
correct the data
we use a bme280 for that
we it's also very important to mention
that we don't do any pre-processing of
data on the sensor
and what that means is that the firmware
itself
is designed to just quite simply um
pick up the raw values
and if it's noisy or if there's any
other kinds of influence going on
we upload the data as is so that we
leave that
pre-processing to you later on so if you
want to
low pass filter it or do some kind of
fancy data analytics on it
you can then one of the reasons for that
is you couldn't
undo processing if we did it on the
sensor so we try to make the data as
unmanipulated as possible so the laser
counter
the sensor is based around this the
heart of it is this pms-5003
i know we got interrupted on the network
connection here and so if i go back to
the previous slide and i'll finish up on
that
and and that's what purple air sensors
measure
and i was talking about not doing any
pre-processing of the data
on the sensor because if you do any
pre-processing on the firmware
you cannot undo it later so we upload
the data as it is
it might be a bit noisy it might pick up
whatever it is that the sensors
have going on it could be no electric
electrical noise it could be
insects in the sense or whatever it
might be and we upload that
raw data to the internet so that you can
choose to do your processing on it
like low pass filtering or whatever it
might be after the fact
so the heart of a purple air sensor is a
device that's made by a company called
plan tower
and it's a pms-5003 our indoor sensors
use the pms-1003 but the p82 uses the
5.03
they basically use lasers to reflect
light off the particles that are in the
air that's being sucked through the
device
and the particle counts the the
estimated particle counts
are used to calculate an estimated
particle mass concentration in
micrograms
now in that process of taking what they
estimate to be the number of particles
and converting it into a mass
concentration
you have to know what the density of
those particles might be
now to do the the conversion they
they uh use what they've determined to
be the
average or uh typical density of
particles
in the wild which can be something like
2.6 or 2.8
grams per centimeter cubed and
it's fair to say that wildfire smoke is
actually a density of around 1.5
grams per centimeter cubed so the
uh microgram values that the sensor
outputs
could have an offset that is that is
basically uh
effect influenced by the exact
density of the particles that it is
seeing
so we also get two values out of the
laser counter one is called cf1 and the
other one is called atm
and according to the manufacturer the
cf1
is meant to be used in controlled
environments like
indoors where you have air conditioning
and other kinds of
controls on the airport or on the air
itself
and the atm is meant to be used for
outdoor environments for atmospheric
conditions and so if you see cf1 and atm
type of units or
like qualifiers on the data fields
that's what they are for
um the propeller map is one of the
cornerstones of what we do
and that is how you can share the data
and how you can view the data
from the network of sensors and
the users will get their sensor and then
you will register it on our website
which will place it on the map
the device the sensor itself is
connected to wi-fi and reports every
two minutes and the in those minute
readings
is what you would be seeing on the map
if you choose real time
now the purple map is also free to use
and uh
you can get real time you can get 10
minutes average you can get a bunch of
different
presentations or averaging periods of
the data
and you can also choose different data
layers so you'll be able to see humidity
you'll be able to see
temperature you'll be able to see all
these different values that the sensor
outputs including the raw particle
counts
and the um different atm cf1
values that you can view on the map
so over the years while we've been
working on on this
we actually have learned a couple of
things about what people want
people want to know what the air quality
is right now they don't want to know
what it was like an
hour ago because they feel like it might
not be representative of what they're
being exposed to at that very moment
they also want to know what it is right
here right where they are where they
live
and in the beginning we had those 80
senses that we gave away
someone said to to me you know i i know
you've got a sensor just around the
corner at the school from where i live
but i want one outside my house and so
that's when we started realizing that we
had to
make them available to purchase because
it didn't make sense for us to place one
for free
and and have one so close by we wouldn't
be able to cover much area if we did
that
so we started selling them the other
thing that's important
that is critically important is the
accuracy
it must be trusted people must trust the
doctor they must trust the values coming
out the sensor otherwise
it will it will not be useful and so
that's where the testing with the ac
spec program came in
and also the other testing is done by
many
other institutions like universities
around the world
and the confirmation of those the of the
readings
from all of those different sources has
really helped to make it trusted
the other thing that's important is it
must be easy to access
you must be able to see the data on any
device at any time
and so we take a lot of care to try to
make the map
and our website compatible on all
devices
including phones and so you will be able
to
read the dots and see the data on any
device
the other thing the biggest thing that
we've learned is just how much people
care unfortunately that image is
covering up
some of the word people but that's
people
and people really care about clean air
i kind of thought in the beginning that
you know utah is a
it's commonly known as a red state um
people here that's on the seal of utas
is industry and we kind of thought that
people would brush it off like oh it's
just smog it's like air pollution get
used to it get over it you know move on
but actually here in utah we got a very
big footprint
of sensors because people really do
care about air quality no matter who you
are
you want to be breathing good air you
don't want to be breathing diesel smoke
and dust and all sorts of pollution
because everyone understands
that it's bad for you so people really
do care about it
so there's a couple of challenges in
what we do
one of them is that left-hand picture
there is meant to be a data tidal wave
and it is a massive massive amount of
data i mean we are dealing with
14 billion records so far and counting
from our collection of net of sensors so
you have to be able to store a large
volume of data you have to be able to
access it you have to be able to analyze
it and that
in itself presents a significant
challenge
not just in costs of storing that data
and collecting it
but in analyzing it like an analytical
um processes on such a huge volume of
data poses its own set of problems
and then the other thing that's really
come central in what we do
is educating users and one of the main
areas of education
is the difference between our network
and regulatory
sensors like why is purple air reading
this and then
air now is reading that and the epa gets
phone calls from people who are
asking these questions and concerned
about it and they think that all sorts
of stuff is going on
in the background to make this you know
that the government is hiding something
or something
but it's fair to say that the regulatory
network was really created to
monitor the effects of legislation
monitor the effects of things like clean
air rules on vehicles
and also to do that over weeks months
and years
it was not really designed to tell you
what the air quality is right now to
make you
able to make a decision about whether
you should go cycling now if you should
go running now if you should go
somewhere else or let the kids be
outside
and so the differences between the two
networks really become apparent
in the desire to make these types of
decisions
and real-time information is very
different to
averaged and regulatory network another
thing that's worth pointing out
is that the difference between the
government census and owls
is something like the government census
need to stand up to scrutiny
if you take a company to court about
polluting
you need to have that data really
rigorously validated you have to have
the sensors that collect the data
calibrated
by you know qualified engineers
and regularly and it has to stand up to
scrutiny documentation all of that
becomes very important
so the purpose of the data and the
purpose of the network is very important
so our goals are to
manufacture high quality low cost air
quality sensors generally those two
terms high quality and low cost don't
always come in the same
sentence so it's quite a tough um goal
to achieve that and we also want to
provide
the map for real-time decision making
and sharing the data we're also
intending on creating localized and
global data air quality sets if you want
to
look at the idea of comparing air
quality in new york compared to london
compared to delhi
wherever you might be looking at air
quality what makes purple
kind of unique and special is that we
have the same technology
deployed in all of these places the same
sensor
in working in the same way according to
the same system
which makes it very easy to compare
directly whereas if you look at
british air quality indexes and british
air quality methods of collecting air
quality data
might differ from us canada
india all of these different places have
different standards they have different
methods and and so it can be hard
to compare like for like across the
world we make that possible
supplement we also want to supplement
regulatory air quality networks so for
instance the epa
likes purple air because we help them to
fill in the gaps between their senses
we help them to understand what it might
be like uh where they don't have sensors
because we have sensors where they have
sensors
so they can get a ground uh comparison
of the baseline and compare what ours
are reading compared to theirs
and then that helps them to let's say
calibrate and fill in the gaps between
their senses and then the other thing
that
purple air has one of another one of our
goals or one thing that we're good at
is getting people interested in air
quality
the south coast and other
groups down in california like the
coalition for clean air
in la they liked the fact that popular
gave them this opportunity and this
ability to start getting people
interested in air quality again because
as
the years went on from the 60s and 70s
where there was horrific air quality
and things got better and cleaner it
became less
obvious in people's minds and it would
take more of a
back seat in in
old everyday life and so people started
sort of forgetting about air quality
and we helped to make that more uh
present in people's minds
today we have over 13 000 senses on the
map
and they're used by anyone from private
concerned or interested citizens to
schools universities
non-profit groups like as i mentioned
the coalition for clean air
in la or peanut carolina in north
carolina
and it's used by government
organizations as well
from air regulators to the fire and
smoke map on air now and
it's also used by news agencies or other
organizations that might report on
weather and air quality
and so they find it beneficial to use
our data to help them to understand what
they can tell their users about air
quality
uh a recent addition to the purple air
ecosystem which we're quite proud of
is the purple air partnership with the
epa on the
fire and smoke map on air now
it is really a very big achievement to
have that level of recognition and we're
very proud of that so the epa did a big
study where they compared
readings across thousands of public
sensors to thousands of epa sensors
across the country
and they came up with a conversion that
would allow them to
compare or to to output numbers that
were more
in line with the official government
sensors
and and they're using that now on the uh
fire and smoke map on the epa's in our
website
so what the epa does with the poplar
data
that they get from us the raw data is
they'll apply a qa and qc process to it
which is basically selecting which
sensors they believe
are in good condition and reporting
accurate numbers
and then they will apply that conversion
factor to that data
and then they also apply what the what's
called the now cost
method um which is just how they process
the uh real time readings into more or
less like a
an average reading that's that's over i
think it's about a three-hour average
with recent or latest data having a
weighted kind of influence on those
numbers
and so they then take those numbers the
output of that
that process and they put it onto their
fire and smoke map
and they do some graphics to try to
estimate where the smoke plumes
are and the idea behind that is to try
to help people get
a filtered and regulatory grade or
regulatory
kind of um i wouldn't say endorsed but
they're trying to just make it that
people can uh
see the smoked plumes in a more trusted
way
so on the horizon uh we have um
work that we're doing in the background
on firmware on making the sensors easy
sensors easier to configure and uh more
friendly to
to the user experience we're also adding
new features to our api
that allows access to the data and more
fields and
improvements to that over time as can be
expected
we're also working in the background on
infrastructure upgrades
which will give us new capabilities with
how the sensors track the pollution
and different types of pollution and
also
more flexibility with that so we're
working on background
upgrades to our infrastructure for all
of that kind of stuff
we're also working on new sensors we're
doing some kind of experimentation with
ozone and voc sensors
which are quite commonly asked for and
so we're
doing some trials and stuff on those
types of sensors right now
and we're also looking at new designs of
our devices to make them easy for us to
make
uh cheaper to make faster to make which
will all be
translated into savings for the end
users at the end of the day
people talk about our sense as being a
little bit more expensive
and yes they are a bit more expensive
because of all of these extras in the
background
like the map and the data storage and
um the cost related to providing all
that that service is
pretty significant but we're hoping to
provide this cheaper sensor that will
help
less privileged communities in the
future and be
able to make the senses more prolific
now in this picture you can actually see
a little uh
secret uh preview if you want to call it
that of what we're calling our spaceship
design
which has got a bunch of leds around it
that that
go with the air quality color and
that's something that we're hoping to be
able to offer in limited current
quantities pretty soon
um and yeah the spaceship design
people like leds like they like um
lights
and uh that's a thank you for for having
me and
um i'll obviously be happy to answer any
questions that you might have and
uh um thank you for listening
so adrian this is this is uh true truly
cool because
what you've done is you've taken a
collection of essentially off the shelf
parts put them together in a special way
and put a whole bunch of them out to be
put on the map and i think that's that's
really wonderful
are you looking at other things that you
could perhaps uh
handle in the same way you know the the
ozone side of it
yes i mean we take our own flavor and
apply it to
to a sensor that's already available and
we we're actually looking at
the aerocoil s900 and we take our
we it's like kind of going back to our
routes where we take the dollar store
literally it's a dollar store bowl
and we make the stevenson screen
improvised housing for it
and so um yeah we're applying our
methods and our construction methods
like for instance the fact that we use a
pvc
end cap for the housing for our pa to do
and we're
adding more devices and we're adding
more uh
types of pollution to our what we're
measuring
well did you are also exploring and
see if you can uh increase the range of
things you can build sensors for uh
you know i was thinking uh possibly even
a seismic sensor or a
well the seismic sensor for example
right so it's a very good question and
um in the very beginning when i was
building the website and the back end
for that
we made it flexible enough that we would
be able to add
more parameters or different types of
sensors
into that so for instance if we had the
ability to connect to collect
noise for instance noise pollution is
another big subject around the world
and if we had a noise sensor if we had a
seismic sensor
we would be able to feed it into the pa2
and have it
upload the data over wi-fi and have it
indexed and
easily create a new layer on the map for
that type of thing
so i guess we've built into the back-end
systems
and the pa2 this ability to
interface with new sensors and
seismic would be a little bit different
because the way that the sensor is
mounted you would have to have it
with a pole into the ground and
something that's a slightly different
mounting strategy
and the same is true for things like
wind speed in wind direction you would
have to have a wind
sensor mounted up high on the roof
you know in more clear airflow
noise would also be a little bit
trickier to measure because you're going
to have to
you know basically mount it in a way
that it's not shielded from noise of
certain types and so
so this this intricacies involved with
measuring different types
of things and and we would have to um
consider those if we were to incorporate
those senses
i can think of one that would be a great
uh joy to have around here
and that is a an e-field measurement
device
which could be used to determine whether
or not locally there's uh
being dry lightning because that's a
major cause of fires in the
northern california area yes and that's
a very interesting idea and something
like that
um would be less susceptible to the
mounting location
because we have our sensors mounted up
under the even roof or
on the side of the house or somewhere
else and so
a sensor like that would probably go
very well with this
um the new designs that we're working on
are expandable
in that it's got a port that you could
plug things into
including something like a more accurate
temperature and humidity
sensor that might not be influenced by
the the latent heat given off by the
sensor itself
so an e-field plug-in
module might be definitely a good thing
for us to look at implementing in the
future
yeah i think it's really really amazing
the things you can do
once you once you you you have you have
a mechanism for reporting data back
and uh you can build uh all manner of
different uh sensors
which uh fit into that uh that
particular uh
framework and i'm i'm just amazed that
no one has uh has uh
has done it widely before this is at
least my first encounter with this um
sure how much is the company one of the
reasons that maybe people haven't done
it before is it's quite difficult to do
you know you've got a lot of expense to
incur with developing online systems
uh people might think oh just you know
put a website out there and have a
database
but uh it's it's a lot more complicated
than that because you've got
um code you've got uh volume of data
you've got real time systems that have
to be online if
you go down for a couple of minutes
you're gonna lose a whole lot of data so
it's really very complicated to create
an overall
you know the hardware the online systems
the databases everything behind it
yeah so how large a company do you have
oh sorry what's the question how many
people oh um
yeah so right now purple air has we
we've got about 25 people
i would say at the moment that work
every day on making census
on support and on the admin side
okay and uh it's privately held i assume
yes um we are privately held we're also
self-funded so
since the beginning um you know in the
very beginning we had some friends who
helped us to
put together resources to make the first
80 senses that we gave away
but since we started selling the sensors
we have been completely self-sufficient
and funded from the sales of the senses
okay
now as an owner operator of these miners
yet or yet to arrive i know you have a
backlog
uh the um the other question is
what in the future will i be able to uh
to get from you
purchase that will allow you to continue
to grow and expand your offerings
so apart from the sensors as they are
that we sell are new versions that might
come out and new types of
things to plug into it like the e-field
measuring
and stuff that we might develop in the
future
we're also looking at other ways to
generate what's called revenue streams i
guess
like premium services on the website
that might help us to
become sustainable uh for instance
we always want to maintain an element of
free access to our map
that people that haven't got any
subscription or membership of any sort
will be able to view the map and get
data to help them to deal with
disasters like the wildfires or just
decide when to go running
but we also might be providing more
advanced features like let's say
notifications
or a longer ability to view longer
history of data
or animations or something like that
that might
be available to subscribers
for a monthly fee that will help us to
exist and to survive
as well as commercial agreements where
if you're using the data in a certain
way
and you're using the api that you you
would be uh subscribing
to get access to that dot to help us to
survive
i think it's wonderful um i
i don't have any further questions i
appreciate your taking the time to
describe the uh
the work that you've been doing and uh
i'm waiting for my
um my versions of the sensors
to arrive in the uh in the fedex or
whatever
very soon i'm uh i'm anxious to get them
up
and um i'm told right at the moment that
we are
uh that the fire that uh
the glass fire in napa it is not far
from where i am
uh is again stirring and that the air
quality is going down
so i'll be checking purpleair.com
uh to find out what's actually happening
and
for that i i really appreciate the work
that you've been doing
thank you very much well dennis i want
to also just close by saying um thank
you to you
and to all of our supporters because
without all of our sense of hosts and
people that buy
sensors contributing towards our
existence we really would not be
here purple air consists of of us in the
office here
and everyone that hosts the sensor and
everyone that looks at the system
and the other thing that i want to
mention is that benefiting from
you know increased sales or like
proliferation of people viewing the map
during something like the wildfires in
california gives us very mixed feelings
the success of it is is a is a great
feeling and then the
tragedy of what's happening there the
loss of property the loss of human life
um and the untold loss of
creatures and and uh you know millions
of insects and animals affected by this
it is a real tragedy and we really feel
forwards what's going on in california
and has also in australia places like
that
it is a real tragedy and what gives us
um the ability to actually sleep at
night
is the fact that people are very
grateful for what we're doing because
we're helping them to understand
the disaster and to understand and scope
a bit better
and we get letters of thank you all the
time so
we want to really acknowledge that it is
a terrible tragedy it's a disaster
and people are suffering and the animals
are suffering and uh
yeah it's it's really terrible okay
and so i thank you very much uh how many
continents are you on
i think we're on almost all of them
except for antarctica because
uh we we have sensors all over the world
now
and uh it might even change we might
even have one in the arctic at some
point but
uh yes well i'll i have a friend who's
there i'll uh
make a suggestion that they get one
sure and the sensors do perform very
well in extreme cold so it would be
interesting to see how they handled that
type of call that's uh sounds like a
very
good test to run yeah we would be happy
to donate some for that purpose too
okay well thank you very much for the uh
for your time
and uh um we'll uh look forward to uh
chatting with you in the future thank
you so much thank you dennis